hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well in his discussion of the
cosmological ideas in part three of his
proma to any future metaphysics Emmanuel
Kant is is going to set out four
antinomies of pure reason in that
section Each of which has a thesis a zot
a proposition and then an antithesis a
gagan zots a counter proposition to it
and these have to do with the nature of
the universe and also with causality as
we're going to see with the others and
the first two that he's going to treat
he calls the
mathematical antinomies and so just a
little bit of review what are these so
the first one runs the thesis is the
world has as to time and space a
beginning and then in parentheses limit
right the antithesis for that is the
world is as to time and space infinite
so what do we have there clearly two
contradictory propositions generally
when we have cont contradictory
propositions we think that one of them
must be true and the other one must be
false so we need to go and figure out
which one it is the second
mathematical antinomy runs the thesis is
everything in the world is constituted
out of the simple and the antithesis is
there is nothing simple but everything
is composite so in both cases we can
talk about
limitations of you know what it is that
we can find within the world as we
experience it and you can say well you
know these are the sort of things that
physicists have great interest in what
are the basic building blocks of the
matter that we actually experience that
are made of does the universe itself end
somewhere or does it go on infinitely
okay so these are some serious questions
now what makes them
mathematical antinomies he says uh
several things so the first is that they
are concerned with the addition or
division of the homogenous the G Aran so
g means equal or equivalent so art is
the the type of thing so we're talking
about things being of the same sort
right so if we're talking about matter
matter is all at at bottom at least we
assume the same sort and notice that
it's not addition and subtraction it's
addition or division which is kind of
interesting and K is going to say okay
these are
antinomies because there's a weird kind
of contradiction going on here they are
as he's going to say founded upon such a
contradictory concept right uh
V beg so a b a concept is what we use to
make sense out of our experience
V uh contradicting right and we're going
to see that it's actually
self-contradictory and if we look up a
little bit earlier just in the same
section we see him saying contradictory
propositions cannot both be false so
contradictory propositions like those
the thesis and antithesis and each of
these antinomies
unless the concept lying at the ground
of both of them is
self-contradictory
so it's not the propositions themselves
where the contradiction lies it's in
something which is zund at the basis of
at the ground of namely a
self-contradictory uh concept he gives
as examples a square circle is round a
square circle is not round which of them
is true well both of them are actually
false
why you know he says as to the former
it's false the circle is round because
it's a square circle it's quadrangular
right and it's likewise false that it's
not round angular because it's a circle
once you've
combined self-contradictory
things within a concept then you know
falsity follows from that when you draw
these these sorts of conclus clusions so
he says that when we assume a concept
like this two contradictory
propositions
become false right and he's going to a
little bit later as he's beginning to
talk about the other uh sort of
antinomies he's going to say in the
first the mathematical class of
antinomies the falsehood of the
presupposition consists in
representing so forell and is the verb
that's used there it's actually for but
um
representing in one concept something
self-contradictory vas V something that
contradicts
itself so and he says it's uh consistent
representing something
self-contradictory here's the problem as
if it were comp compatible
out as if it's able to be unified in
this concept so we're working with
Concepts themselves that have something
weird something off something
self-contradictory to them like a square
circle but it's not quite so easy to
identify when you say Square Circle or
to use another example that haiger will
bring up wooden iron right uh that's a
great example of another
self-contradictory ictory concept so
Kant says all right we need to explain
this uh he says how does it happen that
both the thesis and antithesis of the
two are
false so he says time and space are the
key here when I speak of objects in time
and space it is not of things in
themselves of which I know nothing but
of things in appearance that is
experience as a particular way of
cognizing objects which is only afforded
to human beings I must not say of that
which I think in space or time that in
itself and independent of these my
thoughts it exists in space and time why
because then I contradict myself here's
where the contradiction is actually
going to lie um why space and time he
says and the appearances within them
they're a shining in right are only
modes of representation ways in which we
represent things to ourselves or the
ways they are represented to us and he
says that um they are nothing existing
in themselves and outside of my
representations so it's contradictory to
say that a mere mode of representation
exists outside of our our our uh
representation right we we can't have it
both ways you can say although we're
trying to and we're not seeing that we
do uh try to do that he says objects of
the senses therefore exist only in
experience so to try to give them a
self-subsisting existence apart from
experience or prior to it is to
represent to ourselves that experience
actually exists apart from experience or
prior to it so we've got two different
sides of this you know representing
something to ourselves that is not in
our representations and precedes our
representations uh having experience of
what is not in experience and precedes
our experience these are
self-contradictory according to K right
so this allows us now to look at these
antinomies first antinomy is essentially
is the universe Limited in space and
time does it have a beginning does it
have some bard some boundary that we
could reach or is it infinite is it
without any sort of limitations of that
sort is it Eternal is it you know not
bounded by space so he tells us all
right if we consider the magnitude of
the world it is impossible to declare it
infinite or to declare it finite we
can't declare either of these why not
what does he mean by that well we
they're both false false right so it's
not that we can't say the words it's
just that when we make that assertion or
we think about it we cognize it or we
make that judgment we are making a false
judgment why is that the case says
neither assertion can be contained in
experience by contained he means neither
of these are things that we can meet
with an experience or verify by
experience so he says experience of an
infinite space or infinite time elapsed
or of the boundary of the World by an
empty space or an antecedent empty time
is
impossible these are mere ideas and
remember that idea in this section has a
very important specific meaning for
count there ways in which we sort of
project a
completion that we can't ever meet with
an experience to experience so he says
the magnitude of the world be it
determined in either way would therefore
have to exist in the world apart from
all experience but this contradicts the
concept of the world of sense and what
is the concept of a world of sense
merely a complex of the appearances
whose existence and connection occur
only in our representations in
experience right so he says the concept
of an absolutely existing world of sense
self-contradictory so the solution of
the problem whether attempted
affirmatively or negatively is always
going to be false neither side of the
antinomy can actually be
asserted uh in any sort of true manner
so they're both wrong in some sense but
notice that you can make Arguments for
both of them as well as people have done
in metaphysics up until Kant and
actually after him as well sometimes so
what about the second antinomy where
we're talking about we're no no longer
like looking for a limit to the universe
or a beginning beginning of time but
we're saying when we drill down to use
you know a concept that has crept into
our vocabulary these days and we look at
things I'll use another term very
granularly right when we're looking at
the things at their
basis are they complex or are they
simple if they're complex then we can
break them down further and further and
further maybe we can go down
infinitely or maybe we reach some sort
of Bedrock maybe it's Adams maybe it's
quarks who knows what it is but we reach
that KH says well is the same sort of
thing he tells us that uh divisions of
appearances are mere appearance or mere
representations and the parts exist
merely in their representation
consequently in the division that's an
impossible experience where they're
given and the division reaches only as
far as experience goes so we you know
maybe we could divide further but our
resources for seeing what we're doing
end at this point right now and if you
think about the history of you know
theorizing about the basic building
blocks of matter for a long time people
are like well it's atoms then we have
subatomic particles and then we have yet
even further subatomic particles right
and who knows how far down the rabbit
hole we're going to go so to speak so he
says that here's here's with the payoff
to assume that an appearance contains in
itself before all experience all the
parts which any possible experience can
ever reach is to impute to a mere
appearance which can exist only an
experience an existence previous to uh
to experience so he says in other words
there's another way of saying it it
would mean that mirror representations
exist before they can be found in our
faculty of representation this K says is
clearly self-contradictory the concept
itself
contradicts itself and so he says as
also every solution of our misunderstood
problem so with both of these antinomies
he's explaining to us not just that well
you can make a case for either side both
cases turn out to be false why are they
false because there is a
self-contradictory concept that is being
smuggled in assumed and that's where the
problem lies now being aware of this we
can say to ourselves well we can't make
these sort of
declarations either way we can can think
about them we can assume them if we want
to although we're on Dangerous Ground in
doing so but we can never meet with them
in experience and we can't even
rationally deduce them because they're
both false deriving from a
self-contradictory therefore false
concept